Russia continues to bring death and
Devastation to Ukraine
it is deliberately targeting civilians
and civilian infrastructure
it is seeking to paralyze the country at
the beginning of the winter
but we stand by Ukraine and we will make
Russia pay for its cruelty
the eight packages of sanctions that we
have issued so far are ready biting hard
but today we are stepping up the
pressure on Russia with a ninth package
of sanctions
first we are proposing to add almost 200
additional individuals and entities
to our sanctions list
this includes the Russian Armed Forces
as well as individual officers and
defense industrial companies
but also members of the state tumor
of the Federation Council ministers
governors and political parties among
them
this list covers key figures
in Russia's brutal and deliberate
missile strikes against civilians
and in the kidnapping of Ukrainian
children to Russia
and in the theft of Ukrainian
agricultural products
High representative Borel will tell you
more about this
second
we propose to introduce sanctions
against three additional Russian Banks
this includes a full transaction ban on
the Russian Regional Development Bank
to further dry out Putin's watchest
and third we also want to impose new
export controls and restrictions
particularly for dual used Goods
this includes for example key chemicals
or nerve agents Electronics
I.T components
all what could be used by the Russian
war machine
my first point
we will cut Russia's access to all sorts
of drones and uavs
we propose to ban the direct exports of
drone engines to Russia
and the expert to any third countries
such as Iran
which could Supply drones to Russia
we will also Target the Russian
propaganda machine by taking four
additional channels of the air
and all other distribution platforms
and we propose further economic measures
against the Russian energy and Mining
sector
including a ban on new mining
investments in Russia
this package comes on top of the full EU
import ban on Russian seabon oil that
came into first this week
and on top on the global oil price cap
agreed between the G7 countries
the international cooperation against
Russia's War has never been stronger we
stand firm
And We Stand United